a four thousand dollar hero has emerged
what am I talking about i am talking
about none other than our sixty thousand
dollar fundraiser that we are doing it
david pakman.com slash donate we are 17
days from the Iraq inauguration of
president elect Donald J Trump going to
be a very very dark day for the United
States of America and it will also be
the last day during which you can donate
to our campaign at david pakman.com
slash donate we have had a slowing down
right i'm not gonna come up here and
pretend like the campaign did incredibly
well during the vacation people clearly
from the holiday break and the new
year's break etcetera had their minds on
other things we've had some good
donations were now over 330 total
donations about twelve thousand dollars
have been raised but we need to ramp
things up a bit and fortunately for us a
longtime viewer of the show has come
forward with a matching donation
challenge here's the premise he will
match i think it's okay to say he is a
man but it's the anonymous could be any
man uh he will match dollar for dollar
all donations between now whenever you
hear this or see this clip and the end
of this friday night at midnight Eastern
up to four thousand dollars okay every
dollar you donate from now until the
next four thousand dollars come in will
be doubled if you donate ten bucks
really you're creating a twenty dollar
in flow for the campaign you donate a
hundred bucks you're creating a
two-hundred-dollar in flow for the
campaign if one person shows up at david
pakman.com slash donate and types in
four thousand and donates you have
actually raised eight thousand dollars
for the show because of this matching
donation challenge we need to make sure
that we hit the four thousand bucks
brooke between now and friday because
otherwise we are leaving money on the
table so please donate at david
pakman.com slash donate I won't rehash
the purpose of the whole campaign but i
will remind you we are building
progressive media we are building
progressive activism through a network
of progressive media shows we have to be
organized later today i'm going to
give you my spiel on fact-checking is
not going to stop Donald Trump
Organization is what's going to prevent
Donald Trump from doing horrible things
and this is part of it so please david
pakman.com slash donate four thousand
dollars in available matching funds
through friday at midnight okay so we've
got to do it and on monday i will give
you the results and of course confirm
the the matching donation that will by
then have come in